the MCU Phase 5 has been all up in the
air for the last few weeks as we've had
reports and confirmations from Disney
plus official website that things are
changing for the MCU well today we have
an idea of exactly when to expect Loki
season 2 from Owen Wilson himself hey
everybody how's it going welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm your host for the
day Chris and yes there are a lot of
questions surrounding the MCU phase five
phase six phase seven everything moving
forward and specifically we're talking
about spacing out some of the projects
there have been a lot of debates about
whether or not Marvel has been producing
too much for the culture for fans to be
able to process and enjoy and then on
top of that for that quality that the
MCU has given us throughout the first
three phases to really be present we
have several rumors and some
confirmations from Disney as well for
some of the phase 5 reconfiguration
which we'll be discussing today as well
as Owen Wilson telling us when we should
expect Loki season 2. if you haven't
already consider subscribing and turning
on that notification Bell you can also
check us out on our other socials
Instagram Twitter links to all of that
can be found in the description down
below now there are a lot of
conversations going on around the fandom
about the MCU right now and whether or
not it has quote unquote fallen off now
I don't really like that term because I
do feel like the mcu's experimenting
with new opportunities and possibilities
Disney plus has brought a whole new way
to reach out to fans to the platform the
first three phases the infinity Saga
didn't have Disney plus and phase four
was very experimental and on top of that
we're already aware that Bob chapek was
breathing down Marvel's neck about
getting out as much content as possible
on Disney Plus in order to help secure
subscribers and really push that
platform so putting a lot of weight of
Disney plus and its entire success on
Marvel because we're strong fans hands
and Disney knows that that really leads
us into the topic of today's discussion
and that is the delays the
reorganization and the spacing out of
phase five projects it wasn't long ago
at all that Disney on their official
Disney plus website changed the Loki
biography to coming this summer to
coming soon which was a massive
indicator as they also did that to many
other Disney plus projects that things
are going to start shifting Kevin feige
also is on record talking about quality
over quantity and how they really need
to step up and on top of even that a
major Marvel executive who has been with
Marvel since Iron Man Victoria Alonso
has stepped away from her position
although now we are hearing rumors and
reports that she was in fact Let Go all
these and many other examples and rumors
are leading to The Perfect Storm of
confusion for phase five especially
after Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
did not hold up in the box office now
the movie itself in my opinion and in
many of yours was very very fun and
enjoyable but there was still something
missing from that MCU charm that forced
it to suffer now maybe that was the
lackadaisical overall impression that
phase four left as we were headed into
phase five I certainly anticipated
Ant-Man and the WASP doing better given
that massive introduction to Kang the
Conqueror and subsequent big baddies for
the remainder of the mcu's Multiverse
Saga but today we have our first bit of
Hard Evidence as to when exactly we can
expect Loki season 2 to drop and it it
does seem like it will be coming out
this year still it's just exactly when
is where we can't quite put our finger
but Owen Wilson did have this to say I
guess quantumania has kind of a little
shot of Tom Hiddleston and I and
Jonathan Majors from Loki season two and
I think that's coming out end of summer
or September so end of the summer or
September is what Owen Wilson seems to
think now we don't have or never truly
had a hard date for the release of Loki
season 2 other than what was on The
Phase 5 slate board summer 2023 so end
of summer or September still is not a
massive weight but what we're really
trying to figure out is when everything
in the phase will be coming out it's
nice to hear from Owen Wilson who plays
Mobius in Loki season 1 and 2 has a
approximate idea of when it will be
releasing and Mobius is no irrelevant
character in fact we're all very
confident and have heard all the rumors
that Mobius will also be included in
Deadpool 3 which is going to have a very
important Multiverse explanation
Multiverse conversion bringing the fox
characters the old X-Men the original
Fantastic Four into the MCU and whoever
else might be dragged Along by Deadpool
including of course Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine Mobius is going to be in
charge of that but one of of the biggest
question marks I have for Loki season 2
and for Mobius is what is the job of the
TVA now I ask this because originally in
Loki season 1 he who remains the first
king we were introduced to created the
TVA to keep one sacred timeline the
tva's job was to go around eliminating
other timelines so that no other Kang
variants could be created that was the
entire purpose of the Sacred timeline as
explained by he who remains the Kang
variant that ultimately won the entire
Kang Dynasty War the battle for the
Multiverse as it was explained by Miss
minutes so at the very end of Loki
season 1 when the TVA has now passed
over from he who remains to a different
version of Kang what is the purpose of
that TVA because it isn't any longer to
keep other kings at Bay at least it
might not be it's very possible that
that's what they're actively trying to
do as they fight in this multiversal war
but I'm trying to understand and the
role of the TVA of Mobius as he's
showing up in Deadpool 3 why is he maybe
chasing Deadpool or trying to capture
Deadpool what is the goal of Kang of the
new King in charge of the TVA that
differs from the original he who remains
from Loki season 1. that's a big
question mark that I'm really excited to
get the answer to so I really hope we
don't have to wait too much longer to
get Loki season 2 and honestly it
doesn't seem like that's going to be an
issue we have recent rumors and reports
to give us exactly what idea for the
projects releasing in 2023 are and
here's what this report says now keep in
mind this is not an official update of
the release schedule for 2023 this is
what we have heard from insiders for
2023 phase 5's reconfiguration should
look as follows May 5th 2023 Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 no change there
secret Invasion will be releasing in
June Loki season 2 August and September
release time which does Cohen here with
what Owen Wilson said end of summer
beginning of September X-Men 97 the
Animated Series will be coming out
September or October 2023 the Marvel's
release is November 10th 2023 and iron
heart will be releasing November or
December 2023 and that would also be on
Disney plus so we will have two movies
and then three projects and one animated
project going out on Disney plus also
this report does as I mentioned match up
with what Owen Wilson just recently said
about that release date coming late
summer early September for Loki season 2
so we have a little bit of understanding
cohesion the reports are matching up
which is always a good thing for any
Insider to try to piece together the
puzzle that is Marvel's Phase 5 release
dates right now overall that would leave
us with seven projects Ant-Man in the
Lost quantumania which has already
released Guardians of the Galaxy and the
Marvels as the movies secret Invasion
Loki season 2 and Iron Heart as the live
action Disney plus series and then X-Men
97 as an animated treat which will also
be releasing on Disney us seven projects
for 2023 is that too many or is that not
enough based off of what we're hearing I
know a lot of people don't want to wait
patience is not a virtue for our current
generation tick tocks last less than
five seconds and a lot of different
things going on with moving pages and
changing things and delays from 2020
with kovid we're all kind of over it but
is this something that will ultimately
be better for the MCU you tell me go
down the comment section and let me know
if you're excited about the delays to
give you a little bit of breathing room
a little anticipation for the next
project or if you would be completely
fine with receiving 10 projects every
year from Marvel thank you guys so much
for watching till the very end of the
video if you found it helpful useful or
entertaining consider subscribing and
turning on that notification Bell and
I'll be sure to catch you guys on the
next one right here on the cosmic Wonder
hey